paradolia you know what that means
look it up son paradolia is a
psychological phenomenon in which the
mind
responds to a stimulus usually an image
or a sound
by perceiving a familiar pattern where
none exists basically you look at one
thing
and you're like wow that looks like this
thing that's what we're reviewing here
today
that's what this channel is all about
so let's just jump into it guys let's go
to number one
my favorite picture of trump at his
inauguration today
ah snap i
especially like this one because it's
trash
trash it's kind of cute actually
looks like some anime offspring cartoon
version that just got cancelled
oh oh it's the lid the lid is yellow
oh that's amazing well played wow
patrick stewart
dammit i wish i wish i didn't read the
title first
if you don't know who patrick stewart is
here you go
let's get a side by side on this patrick
stewart reincarnated into a dog
everybody
pyre dola huh it's weird how it's
turning me on a little bit
just me show me what you got oh damn
it's satan oh of course
i forgot we're on reddit that's a that's
a rick and morty reference
show me what you got boss fight
that looks like the final boss of like a
silent hill game or something
all right i'm not gonna read the title
well that's a buffalo are you kidding me
if that's not a buffalo
out in the fields my mind is going to be
blown what is it
one of those dentist lights that you
pull down
oh i hate it it's a buffalo okay
yeah it's at the dentist yeah happy
water bottle at the dentist
god damn that's awesome it looks like
he's wearing
headphones oh my god
incredible it reminds me of that what
has been seen cannot be unseen
but actually you know like the 007
golden eye
cover you you look at your entire life
and you're like that's
that's james bond and then you see this
and you're like god damn it it's ruined
forever
stop it stop that nbc
news poll american fears of war growth
okay what do we got we got a missile
shooting up a penis is that it no tell
me this doesn't look like a squirrel
coming
this is it this is it
we finally uncovered it our god has
revealed himself for us
finally it's beautiful we're gonna hit
them with that what we got
the best we got let's get the squirrel
nukes that's a deep
nut that one i don't know why i scroll
that never scroll down
corolla smoking a cigarette and using a
selfie stick
okay sure i'll be the judge of that yep
yep that's what it is who looks at a
photo
and says that i mean i agree 100
but it's just like why it looks like it
has a selfie stick and it's smoking
jesus christ again why does it turn me
on
is there is it just me smash like if
it's just me
can't unsee okay okay it's one of those
can't unsee one
is it me guys is it just me or do the
trees from pokemon look like
angry men god damn it god damn it
pokemon is ruined
i can't don't see it now again
why am i turned on that tree is swole
though let's get real here
ever been so angry even your pecs were
angry
damn that tree is hard man
yosel okay god damn i was driving my car
and then all of a sudden they just went
yeah
god damn it car you're a car i hope your
car seat makes this sound
let me guess oh that's awesome
stop being so clever reddit okay okay
i'm not gonna read it i'm not reading it
i'm not reading the title
all right what do we got it's an order
it's an
order but it looks like it what the
frick is that made on purpose
no that cannot be a coincidence is it me
or just an
upside down picture of a tiger [ __ ] look
like a [ __ ]
hey reddit what are you doing you can't
use the r
word that just looks so much like an
otter
no this one isn't turning me on or is it
hmm okay okay
okay i'm not reading i'm not reading
well that says wally
who murdered wally who did it who did it
guys
disappointed maybe that's where they
took the inspiration from
it's not unlikely okay not reading okay
[Music]
what the hell had that box been slurping
homeless man was living in a box the box
became homeless
this is so sad can this video smash 500
million
likes thank you oh my god
free him the poor dog how could you do
this
can't keep that dog trapped in there
again it looks delicious why am i turned
on
is it bread or is it cupcakes it's
cupcakes right i want to eat it
it's just slurping some spaghettios very
nice
sometimes me and marcia sends a picture
if we find like a house
or a window like that looks like a face
but this is
that's this pretty legit mate a very
good this little squirt of lotion
looks like a tiny cat why is there a
squirt of lotion on your hand
okay we don't need to see your prefab
revelations okay
although it does look like a cat and yes
i am
extremely turned dude okay what is this
i don't see what this looks like
what does this look like you're oh my
god oh my god oh my god
oh my god that jawline is perfect
god damn when your belly is happy to see
be here
oh that's a great one this is so fun
can we hit 5 billion likes thank you
it's so much more fun if you don't read
the title i'm crying
so happy for them it's beautiful you can
find love anywhere these days
see i wish they didn't put the seal but
i agree that 100
that seal does look like a potato i was
standing in line
waiting to order food but the back of
this dude's head
kept trying to talk to me cannot unsee
this is how he showed up in my feed
jesus christ sometimes you just feel
like
god is speaking to you this is it oh
yeah
oh yeah that house is up to no good that
house has some secrets
or is this smoke some weed i don't know
oh my god
i feel like if you were high and you did
this it'd be hilarious
because it's so dumb a porg trying to
swallow a banana
porg of course which is those stupid new
star wars uh
creatures i mean i looked at it for the
longest time i'm like no that doesn't oh
god damn it that's a late isn't it yeah
late in the while that's pretty cool
oh god what is this oh my god
donald trump again why is donald trump
everywhere
what the hell what do what do i owe you
are you
local rock in great mood today
smash like if you're awesome and share
with all your friends
oh my god the fuel cap cast the shadow
of batman how to
summon mini batman everybody the fuel
cap you need
but don't deserve oh get me this
suspicious
chicken looks at their cupboard like
that
stephen hawking where
where i don't see it oh my god
i'm just disappointed god damn it
now i can't see it see what i mean when
turning on
hmm you ever been turned on by your
sandwich
damn that sandwich is thick
oh why does trees gotta do me like this
why do trees gonna put me through dead
memes
this is so sad usb chad
is busy
no don't do this to me usbs
oh my god i can't look at my usb the
same way
so going to snare with me chad see guys
this is the dumbest episode of anything
anything
but god damn it it's so cute she's so
glad you finally noticed her
what do what are you doing see this is
the thing with marvel movies they're so
uninspired they're just they literally
just look at anything and steal it
so pathetic i don't steal out of their
ideas so
virtual reality
it pisses me off now i'm just getting
pissed off carrot about to drop the
healthiest verse
of all time damn
oh yeah it's about to do it's doing the
gangnam style
oh [ __ ] someone coming in oh my god the
yogurt
the yogurt must rise up yogurt the most
oppressed
breakfast of all time damn damn
you see what i mean turned on if you're
not turning
no okay everybody that's it for
melanonia
a new word that you've learned now that
you can use to impress people
remember patagonia thank you for
watching this video
of whatever i just did i hope it was
enjoyable if it did
you know what to do i don't have to keep
telling you as always
we're gonna end this episode with a
brofist on the side of the screen
are you ready ha ha tricked you left
hard
get trolled
[Music]
you